[Music]
hello and welcome to all of you our
brothers and sisters in the Lord welcome
to i' like to know our Bible question
and answer program where we get the
privilege and pleasure of answering your
questions from the word of God my name
is C Murray and I'm in the company of
Pastor David Salazar and Pastor Steven B
gentlemen always good to have you here
as we study the word of God together
amen feeling is mutual yes and praise
the Lord again uh as you know we we we
like this program and we we like one
another the rumors are true we do love
each other in the Lord we get along well
and um amen it's it's nice to come to
work in a place where people have the
same mindset as you this mind that is
Christ has put in all of us draws us
together we see that many times because
though we we study independently a lot
of times we have the same text and same
scriptures because the Holy Spirit sort
of brings our minds to the same place so
it's fun uh to to kind of see what
little being each of us can put in the
pot in the stew as it were uh as we
study the word of God we want to
encourage you should you like to get in
on the fun and be part of this exper
experience send your questions to TV at
sutv that's s
mv.org TVM tv.org and we will get to
your questions just as quickly as we can
you will note that we don't rush through
the questions so it's not volume or
quantity we want quality answers from
the word of God for you if you take the
time to write we want to take the time
to answer and we make you that pledge
and that promise so Pastor if you would
pray for us please as we begin we'll
launch out into our questions for this
very day Father in heaven we have many
important questions for this
program and we want to answer in harmony
with your will so we ask that the same
spirit that inspired the Bible will be
present with us to teach us and through
us to share with others we plead for
your presence because only the spirit
who gave the word is able to explain it
correctly to us so we place ourselves in
your hands in the precious name of Jesus
amen amen amen and amen our first
question for today comes to us from
Joseph and it is Medford US USA I don't
know if this is Medford Oregon uh which
is the closest Medford that I know of
but there may be other Medford in the
United States but thank you for sending
your question
Joseph in 1 Corinthians 15 Paul speaks
about Christ's
Resurrection from the the dead and that
those who have given their lives to
Christ and are baptized into his death
shall be resurrected into his life but I
have run into some pseudo-christian
denominations he calls them that believe
and practice baptism by proxy meaning
that their priests will perform a
ceremony for the loved one of a dead
person and with their equipping from the
Holy Spirit they claim to have have the
power and authority to baptize the
deceased person and believe that that
newly baptized dead person will be in
the resurrection of the righteous can
you please explain to them and everyone
that that
is else that is deceived by this that is
not
biblical all
right okay I think first of all uh CA
what are the qualifications to be
baptized you got to be alive man you
have to you have to be breathing uh when
Christ gave their great Great Commission
uh he said you've got to teach them to
observe all things last I heard it's
hard to teach a dead person anything so
you can't teach them you can't train
them you can't you can't you can't um
instruct them when they're dead um
baptism is a an outward expression of a
decision that has been made between that
that individual and Jesus Christ so as
such there can be no proxy baptisms
because a dead person cannot make a
decision to follow the lord um I'll put
a comma there and uh sort of Leave it to
one of you
guys well people need to repent they
need to confess their sins they need to
have faith in Jesus those are
qualifications for baptism oh yes the
Bible tells us and none of those things
can be done
by somebody else in place of someone
else precisely I mean that the Bible
doesn't teach that of course and also we
know from the Bible the state of those
who are death they have no more thoughts
they have no more reason they have the
or their works are done they are in a
state of sleep or the speaks of that of
sleep in the sense that they are they're
they cease to to to to be alive to be
able to to think or anything of that
nature so the state of the death in the
Bible is clearly defined as someone who
has no longer any option any ability any
thought any idea and so it's impossible
for Christ who died for those who
professed and confess his name who
confessed their need of a savior for him
to force through any means anyone to
that rejected or that not live according
to to to the light of coming to Christ
somehow saving them through Pro proxy it
just does not make sense uh we have to
understand that the Bible is very clear
as far as the like like you said the
requirements and the qualifications that
are needed for somebody to be baptized
or be part of the faith and that has to
start with someone who is alive and who
comes to Christ by his own choice you
know uh the only church that I know of
that baptizes for the Dead uh is the
Church of Jesus Christ of Latter-day
Saints known better as the Mormons M uh
I'd like to say something about the
Mormons they have a lot of very good
values they have good health values good
family values you know and they're nice
people you know the two missionaries
that come to homes uh you know they're
they're good kids they're young guys on
bicycles but but in this particular
Point as well as in others they're just
not just wrong what they're teaching and
practicing is not biblical the one verse
that would seem to indicate that that
you can baptize for the dead is 1
Corinthians 15: 29 and I'd like to offer
an explanation for that verse uh it says
there in 1 Corinthians chapter 15 verse
29 by the way this is the chapter about
the death and resurrection of Christ and
baptism is included here it says in
verse 29
otherwise New King James Version
otherwise what will they do who are
baptized for the dead if the dead do not
rise at all why then are they baptized
for the
dead now the Apostle Paul here is not
saying you should baptize for the dead
no he's saying why are you baptizing for
the dead rhetorical argument this is
something that they are doing he's not
condoning it he's not supporting it the
Corinthians were
notorious for messing things up yeah you
know they had issues with marriage they
had issues with the gift of tongues they
they had Twisted so many things and they
were baptizing for the dead Paul is
saying you know if the dead don't
resurrect why are you baptizing for the
dead of course he's not recommending it
no he's simply repeating a practice that
they are following without saying yes or
no and so to make this a command of Paul
is simply not there yeah in the text out
of context when you dealing when you're
dealing with first and 2 Corinthians
you've got to start with the premise and
understand that Paul is addressing a
church that is in trouble it is doing
things wrong so when it it talks about
tongues when it talks about some of
these other things and of course having
done 117 funerals I spent a lot of time
in 1 Corinthians 15 uh back into the
book you know around 53 um so when you
see what looks like a commendation
you've got to look at the context
because he's really trying to fet out
some problems that exist in this church
and and and I won't say all but most of
his counsel to this this church is is
trying to straighten out things that
that they've gotten wrong that they've
turned upside down and that has to be
the context for looking at first and 2
Corinthians I mean they had a lot of
teachers that would come or would come
among themselves you know right with
these very Greek ideas doctrines that
are you know coming from paganism so
some of these concepts of or ideas of
you know baptizing for the death
probably came from that mentality from
that teaching from paganism and so it is
it's it's important that we you know
understand like Pastor B mentioned that
the verse is is Paul is just basically
saying why are you doing it if it's not
going to work is it doesn't have any
benefit and and and that's how he's
implying he's not condoning or saying
that it's a practice that we should be
doing as Christians and again the Bible
is very clear and defining that baptism
needs to be a personal decision somebody
has to know has to be alive as you
mentioned you know even though it's it's
almost you know a given but you have to
make a decision while you're alive to
give your life to the Lord once you're
dead that's it there's no more chances
for you to be saved if you have rejected
the Lord that's it that is the end
provision for you at the same time the
Bible says that it is appointed for men
to die once and after that the Judgment
uh so when a person dies that's it yeah
their their case is closed their
decision is final yes it is illegitimate
to Bap baptize someone in the church
without giving them a thorough
understanding of what they're joining
amen you know when we uh this big
meeting they had in papun guini there
were thousands of thousands of people
who gave their heart to the Lord during
the meeting but they refused to baptize
them because they haven't trained them
they haven't taught them but they said
we'll hold them till after we' trained
them so that they know what they're
getting into so that they can be
faithful so the instant baptism uh is is
is a little counterfeit and uh you got
to train first and then you baptize
teach them Jesus said teaching them to
observe all the things that I commanded
you that's very important very very
important indeed all righty um good work
gentlemen uh well done let's go to our
next question and um this is from
Abigail again we don't have a location
and we don't we don't want to be uh a
pain about this but please if you get a
chance let us know where you're running
from it would help us uh so very very
much Abigail has a question asking what
happened in 1888 in the 7th Day
Adventist Church I can't seem to
understand what happened but uh but it's
up in so many books of Ellen White
please Pastor bore and Company so we'll
take that for us P can you explain it in
a simple way so she doesn't want the
heavy theological stuff she wants us to
sort of break down what happened in 1888
at the 1888 General Conference held in
Minneapolis uh Minnesota
um superintended by
ellot Jones and Alonzo T Wagner and
Ellen White by the way Alonzo Jones and
EJ Wagner EJ Wagner yes at Jones EJ
white and EJ white yeah and white and
Butler and your asmith yep they were
there at all yeah so let's walk through
what happened uh uh because there there
there was not a change in our our
doctrines per se it was a more it was it
was more a change in our theological
presentations in a
readjusting of who was at the head of
the spear uh we had put the law kind of
up there to the denigration of Jesus
Christ so it was a
reorientation as to what was most
important and who should come first yeah
the bottom line is that you cannot
understand the 1888 General Conference
session unless you get understand it in
context in the context of what was going
on before prec
White had said that we preached the law
until uh you know until it was like the
hills of gilboa with no do a Reign A
Reign yes so basically the church had
fallen into legalism the idea that you
have to be obedient in order for God to
accept you so the reaction was uh the
message of Jones and Wagner that we are
saved by grace through faith and as a
result that of that then Works follow
yes in other words the church was
putting the cart before the horse
precisely and so Jones and Wagner are
saying let's put the horse before the
cart right and you know so many books
have been written about this and it's
complicated so many times by by
theologians but I want to read a
statement that that puts it in a
nutshell a short paragraph that gives us
the
explanation uh this is found in the book
evangelism it's page
190 and 191
it
says the message was to bring more
prominently before the world the
uplifted
Savior the sacrifice for the sins of the
whole
world it presented justification through
faith in the
shity in other words in our guarantee in
the shity it invited the people to
receive the righteousness of Christ with
is no merit of ours the righteous of
Christ now here comes the key portion
which is made
manifest in obedience to all of The
Commandments of God
Amen many had lost sight of Jesus yes
they needed to have their eyes directed
to his Divine person his merits his
changeless love for the Human family so
basically it's faith in Jesus as the
shity which is made manifest visibly yes
by observance of all the Commandments of
God that's the 1888 conference in Ana
Ina in um also in the 18888 materials
referring to what you had said as a
people we have preached the law until we
are as dry as Hills of gooa which is a
term she uses quite a number of times
that rain we must preach Christ in the
law we uh this is from the 1888
materials also we had preached and and
it was a natural reaction to what they
saw going on around them uh there was no
respect for the law no one was preaching
the law so you T to skew your
presentation to the law because you
don't want a sort of LAX lean kind of
mindset so let's let's Hammer the law
but in doing so we had squeezed the
grace of Christ out of it so the
preaching was draw keep the law keep the
law keep the law keep the law but what
about Jesus he needs to be the center
and then the lawke keeping flows out of
him and that's what she was pressing for
yeah it was a sort of a correction in
the way that we needed to present our
message because it had been going in a
direction that was becoming legalistic
becoming in a sense of Salvation by
works in a in in that IND Direction and
so the lord gave the message to give us
a a real correction in the presentation
of the message of how it should be as
you mentioned presenting Christ and how
the law is to be kept through the power
of Christ through his Justice in our
lives working in behalf of us but there
is a danger today of going into the
Other Extreme which is something that we
are seeing so much now because we are
have departed from the law and kind of
forgotten the fact that we need to have
that obedience to the law by the part of
Christ working in our hearts and we sort
of say now let's emphasize only in the
aspect of justification by by faith or
by Grace only without realizing that
this is again a
misdirection and the enemies pursuing
that way for us us to you know depart
from the middle from the balance that
the Lord wants us to have so this is
important to that's a reason why we have
a Martin Luther and a John Wesley
exactly Martin Luther was justification
Wesley said yes but it leads to a holy
life yes that's the reason why we need a
Paul and a James MH Paul says we're
justified by faith yes without the works
of Law and James says no we're justified
by works but we need to understand what
he's saying exactly he's saying that
we're justified by a faith that works
amen and Paul is speaking of how we're
Justified not by works that we do
previous to our justification so there's
no contradiction between Paul and James
it's just that Paul is telling us how to
be saved and James is saying how a saved
person lives exactly amen so so uh
there's absolutely no contradiction yeah
um go ahead I was going to say it's the
tension between the two but it's not
really the tension it's the balance
between the two that they they both must
exist but um uh one flows out of the
other and if you have one the natural
response to having that is to do the
works of God you know and basically
Satan works on the principle of the
pendulum what you were bringing up he
swings things way left and then he
swings things way right right and he
doesn't care if we're in one extreme or
the other those you he just doesn't want
us to be in the middle exactly you know
so so if we swing way to the side of
Grace and ignore the law or if we
gravitate towards the law and we cast
aside Grace he's perfectly happy whether
we because we can't be saved by our
merits and we can't be saved in our sins
and he knows it so it says let's lead
these people to to the extreme and I
believe that now we are where you
mentioned we are on the side where the
grace of God Is So emphasized that
people no longer are concerned about
keeping the law and about being obedient
to the Lord I'll give you an example the
Seventh Day Adventist Church has a
strong uh a strong um
teaching that we're not supposed to use
jewelry you can make that legalistic or
it can be not
legalistic it's legalistic if you think
that well if I don't use jewelry you
know I'm going to be following God's
Will and God is going to save me but on
the other side you can look at from a
different perspective if I really love
Jesus I'm not going to put anything on
me that attracts attention to me but
that rather attracts attention to Jesus
so so it can the the rule against
jewelry can have a Christ centered
reason or a legalistic reason the issue
is not the standard the issue is what is
the motivation for the standard that we
have yeah and that is so true with with
most of not all lifestyle issues you
know you can do it to try to gain favor
or to Curry favor or to force Jesus to
save you or you can do it as a
consequence of your love for him if I
love you I'm not going to do anything
that disturbs you upsets you or that you
don't want me to do so the the the to
use a a a term the pre-existing
condition has to be love for Christ and
our love for Christ flows a natural
obedience amen and you know you know
Pastor you mention in both of you this
this concept of of the enemy trying to
make us stand in one area or the other
one extreme or the other it's something
that Satan has always seen effective in
destroying God's people within you know
bringing us to go to one way or the
other right now as you mentioned I I see
that the majority lean to the Grace but
as Jude mentions you know a lot of these
folks who are teaching Grace they're
actually turning the grace of God into
lasciviousness in other words
lawlessness you know it's like we don't
need to really keep and you know the the
law of God you know God will saves in
your sins and we are turning ourselves
into individuals or or a church that is
is is turning away from the purity of
the message from turning away from the
purity of being uh people who have been
called to live to a higher standard and
the elements that we see in our midst
you know the elements in what we watch
what we do how what we wear it is
evidences that we are turning away from
the word of God and trying to please the
Lord and just to find a way to live our
lives in sin and think that we are safe
but this is why God has given us a clear
indication clear evidence of the word of
God where are we to stand and and if you
don't like P you know
particularly The Other Extreme but you
have to be willing to understand that
you know God call us always to a higher
standard to a higher walk and you have
to be just humble and say Lord you know
I on myself might be you know deceived
help me not to be deceive help me to
follow your word through the power of
Christ yes and I I think we need need to
mention also that this 1888 message you
know we're 135 years on the other side
of it it's kind of settled in but at the
time it was a radical change to how what
we were doing doing it did not go down
in some courts right easy many people
fought it because they thought it would
it it would swing the pul them back to
oh we don't talk preach law then folk
are going to get loose and LAX and slack
but it had to be balanced and Ellen
White put the weight of her office
behind Jones and Wagner to let them know
this is God's position for the church I
like to illustrate it this way supposing
you're driving down a icy
Road just winter snowing icy mhm and and
um the question is which ditch would you
rather fall into the left ditch or the
right
ditch neither
one in most cases you're going to have
to call a wrecker pull you up put some
chains on your on your wheels you
know stay where the rubber beats the
road precisly exactly that's the point
it is a good point you know over and
over uh the people of God have had to to
adjust themselves to the times in which
they they do but the gospel is still the
gospel it is still pure uh I've heard
people preaching you have to once you're
saved there's nothing you can do to get
out of God's will well no Bible doesn't
teach that teach that you don't lose
your freedom of will precisely exactly
precisely you you have to it's an an an
elected thing you know there this goes
back to the question from from uh from
before um does the the the priest or the
pastor have the power to put you in
without your your will well no it's it's
oneon-one between you and God you can't
save your wife you can't save your
children you can't save your parents the
only person you can save or put
cooperate in the Salvation experience is
you and then as my mom used to say every
tub has to rest on its own bottom I
don't know if that's Indiscreet or not
but uh it was
true it has been said it has been said
it cannot be taken back again we we do
have fun here and and and Abigail hope
we we really wrestled with your question
and solved it to your satisfaction
because it is a serious question and uh
there are many many books on the 1888
movement the 1888 studies and you can
certainly bone up on those should you
wish to do so again so quickly our F our
time has fast slipped into eternity
Allah be in closing to wish you both
Grace and peace through our Lord and
Savior Jesus Christ bye-bye God bless
[Music]